and uh and i'm going over to vote
with my wife and then i'll be happy to
take your questions after i vote okay
we get uh i just completed in here
another public health preview
with my team of public health experts we
looked at the latest
reported data on how it indicates that
we're on an upward slope
of a bigger wave of confirmed infections
than
anything we experienced to date we
talked about what actions would be
needed to turn this around and
how we made worse by this
administration's declaration of
surrender
to the virus and we discussed again
the vital importance of wearing masks of
protecting yourself
protecting your neighbor and to save
around a hundred thousand
lives in the months ahead between now
and just
after the first of the year this is not
political
it's patriotic wearing a mask
where one period be focused on the way
this virus is hitting communities of
color
much harder particularly black latino
and native american communities
we're seeing race-based disparities
across the aspects of this virus
higher infection rates but lower access
to testing
and harder time quarantining safely
because of
their financial circumstances lower
access to quality treatment
when they are infected and tragically
higher mortality rates
one in 1 000 black americans have died
from this virus
this is a staggering statistic and 57
of black adults 46 of latino adults
know someone who has died or been
hospitalized from this disease
folks we've lost more than 220
000 lives of this virus already but this
administration has just given up
over the weekend the white house chief
of staff mark meadows went on television
and admitted that they've waived the
white flag and declared surrender
he said quote we're not going to control
the pandemic end of quote
the american people deserve so much
better than this just look at what
happened last night
in omaha after trump after the trump
rally ended
hundreds of people including older
americans and children were stranded
in sub-zero freezing temperatures for
hours
several folks ended up in the hospital
it's an image that captured president
trump's whole approach to this crisis
he takes a lot of big pronouncements he
makes a lot of big pronouncements
but they don't hold up he gets his photo
off and he gets out
he leaves everyone else to suffer the
consequence of his failure
to make a responsible plan it seems like
he just doesn't care much about it
and the longer he's in charge the more
reckless he gets
it's enough it's time to change
meanwhile yesterday the white house
science office this
stunned me put out a statement listing
ending the covet 19 pandemic as a top
accomplishment of president trump's
first term
top accomplishment of trump's first term
at the very moment when infection rates
are going up almost every state in our
union
the refusal of the trump administration
to recognize the reality we're living
through
at a time when almost a thousand
americans a day are dying
every single day it's an insult to every
single person
suffering from coping 19 and every
family
who's lost a loved one there's nothing
more personal there's nothing nothing
more personal to an american family
than their health care and the health
care of their loved ones
i know all too well what it feels like
to have your heart ripped out
losing a loved ones too soon to sit the
hospital bedside and feel like there's a
black hole
in the middle of your chest knowing
there's not much you can do
i and many of you know what it feels
like to watch a beloved
person die why they're dying of cancer
or some other disease
without wondering having to wonder about
whether you're going to
pay for the medical bills or what would
happen if god forbid the insurance
companies were able to come in and say
you know we're not going to cover the
treatment and yet today
president trump is on a single minor
crusade to strip
americans of their health care that
would only create another enormous
crisis in the public health system
in two short weeks exactly one week
after the election
the trump administration will make its
case asking the supreme court
to strike down the affordable care act
quote in its entirety
in its entirety let me say that again
their argument that the entire law must
fall
which will strip 20 million americans of
their health insurance overnight
rip away protections for pre-existing
conditions for more than
100 million people in the middle of an
upswing
of a pandemic the upswing
look just this week on 60 minutes
we heard what trump told leslie stahl
about the upcoming supreme court case
on the affordable care act and i quote i
hope that they end it
it'll be so good if they end it end of
quote
there's no question there's no question
that's why president trump nominated
justice barrett to the court
that's why the republicans jammed her
through the confirmation of minimum
election
republicans have tried and tried and
tried
since the affordable care act was passed
overturning
and every single time they fail
president trump has tried everything he
can on his own to sabotage the law
so now to what i have characterized as a
craven abuse of political power
they've added to the court of justice
who criticized chief justice roberts
previous decision to uphold the
affordable care act
in hopes that they can destroy the
affordable care act once and for all
through the courts no matter how many
americans they heard in the process
so let's remember exactly what's at
stake in this election
if you have diabetes asthma cancer or
even complications from cover 19
you're going to lose the protection this
law provides
insurers will once more be able to jack
up your premiums or deny your coverage
women could again be charged more for
their health care
just because they're women and children
will no longer be able to stay in their
parents insurance policies
until age 26 on top of all that
overturning the aca could mean that
people have to pay to get
coven 19 vaccine once it's available
that's right that's right the law that
says insurers are required to cover
vaccines for free is the affordable
care act and he's striking that down
attempting to unlike donald trump
i believe healthcare had been a
privilege it's a right that everyone
have access to
this country can't afford former years
of a president but thinks he's
only responsible for the well-being of
the people who voted for you
we can't afford former years of a
president instead of fighting the virus
attacks doctors i can't get over this
guy he attacked
doctors claiming they're over reporting
covet cases
because they want to make more money
doctors are over reporting
cases because they want to make money
you know our doctors and nurses and our
front line health care workers are
putting themselves at enormous risk
every day
more than a thousand of them have
already died
an attempt to beat back this pandemic
and save lives
they deserve to be treated respected by
their president
we can't afford four members of a
president who'd rather spend his time
desperately trying to strip people of
their healthcare
than even once bothered to put forward a
healthcare plan on his own
we can't afford former years of donald
trump
the good the good news is we have a
chance to turn this around by voting
we have six more days left in this
election the american people have it in
their hands
to put this country in a vastly
different path
this is my commitment to you i'll
protect and build on the affordable care
act
so you can keep your private insurance
or choose a medicare-like option
you can make it stronger i'm going to
make it stronger
with your help to lower premiums
and deductibles and out-of-pocket
expenses
we'll bring down drug prices by almost
two-thirds
by taking steps such as allowing
medicare to negotiate
with the pharmaceutical companies or
making billions of dollars
making the price lower when they
negotiate medicare says we're only going
to pay you x amount for
the following medicines that will lower
prices drastically
making and available to everyone we're
going to make sure every american has
access to free
coven 19 vaccine this isn't beyond our
capacity
now if we come together we can stand
together
if we stand together as the united
states the united states
democrats republicans and independents
we can transcend old divisions and show
what's possible there's nothing beyond
our capacity
there's no limit to america's future
if i'm elected president as i said
yesterday in warm springs georgia
i'll be a president who is not in it for
himself but for others
president who doesn't divide us but
unites us president who appeals
not to the worst in us but the best in
us the president looks not to
settle scores but to find solutions
president guided not by wishful thinking
but by
science reason facts
even if i win it's going to take a lot
of hard work to end this pandemic
i'm not running in the falls promise of
being able to end this pandemic by
flipping a switch
but what i can promise you is this
we will start on day one doing the right
things
we'll let science drive our decisions
we will deal honestly with the american
people and we'll
never ever ever quit
that's how we'll shut down this virus so
we can get back to our lives
a lot more quickly than the pace we're
going at now
you know i'm gonna fight to protect your
health care i promise you
just like i fight for my own family we
can do this
i promise you now i'm gonna go do what i
hope all of you do
i'm gonna walk out of this building i'm
gonna go vote
i'm gonna go vote there's a lot of
people on that ballot not just me but
the down ballot as well
that are going to change things for us
make it better
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops
thank you
we got
you